what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
play a stop being polite and start
getting creo
this is the champion I don't call them
three kicks I call them free goals it's
a true that I sleeve it all my hat-trick
balls I have so many now I'm worried
that might contract an STD a sweet
transfer deal uh hello this was filmed
two weeks before the air did so could
you let me know in the comments if I've
been sacked yet
I scored hat-tricks like it's my job
wait that is your job though right so
that is good
[Music]
he's high time the media gave us keepers
I do yeah they don't appreciate that
okay okay yes we all agree but we are
moving on to new business I would like
to mention that sometimes our own clubs
don't appreciate us
okay danke Keller now does anyone have
anything that's not about being
underappreciated I want to say something
I think that keeper should at least have
the option to wear the same kit as the
rest of the squad right all right here's
my proposal okay listen I know I'm a
Yank but I got I'll let you hear me out
hear me out I said goalies should be
able to wear big hats that can cover the
entire goal so I mean you can just
basically sit on your butt and your hat
would block the whole goal all right
anyone else I'd like to introduce a new
motion the chair recognizes Germany's
number two I think it's time we have a
vote for a new president of the
goalkeepers Union don't get me wrong
Manu has changed the game for keepers
but he needs to admit that he is no
longer as a face of the keeper position
I
is this a keepers union hey no strikers
are loud it's okay I'm not a striker I'm
an attacking midfielder same thing no
outfield players get out of here bear
hander it's urgent I need to speak to
you or else we're all going to die vice
that's so funny My dear Roy I'm do it do
you think as keepers for all our time in
solitude have not pondered our own
mortality no you don't understand this
is an emergency if we do not act US will
be destroyed by Thursday oh no I have a
matter on Thursday
so why should we listen to you for those
of you who don't know me I was a very
important at relevant player until like
a year ago my name is Thomas Muller aka
the home daughter which roughly
translates to space investigator or
interpreter it's very cool actually but
my god okay right right sorry so I was
investigating some space like space
space when I noticed something in the
sky a giant meteor heading straight for
us so what do you expect us to do you
are all the best in the world when it
comes to stopping things from heating
their targets right I'm asking you
goalkeepers to save earth so we are
supposed to just fly up into space and
forge a meteor I haven't figured that
part out yet I have an idea hell are you
under it'd be a tough starting keeper
Shakhtar Donetsk I think I know how we
can stop this meteor
meet Ziggy Gonski mega vrata also known
as baldra
girlfr after the meltdown in Chernobyl
the Soviet apparatus proposed a secret
plan to send giant : robot to boot the
reactor core into space but the plan was
ultimately deemed too stupid and goal
Tran who stowed away indefinitely
how do you know all of this I used to be
backup goalie for Pripyat rankin's so
how does it work
it is piloted by five goalkeepers for
controlling each limb and one in the
head that means we'll need our top five
goalies so I'm out right okay
Edison Allison you take the lazy or
black the hair the arms and I'll take
the head Manuel Neuer the original
sweeper keeper Manuel nobody is a
denying your historical greatness but
you've had injuries you're are getting
older it happens to the best of us but
who would you replace me with Tess taken
he can't be the lead he can't even
decide on a first name and your leaders
into space like the time you led us up
the field against South Korea there's no
time forces I will drive let's just go
with the two Germans
[Applause]
[Music]
poor care folks this thing is coming in
fast we need to get the directions
coming left no useful person that's
right we need to dive right I think we
need to rush it and slide tackle it in
open space agreed for thrush I don't
know boys I think we stay on our line
you get a better read on yeah good idea
99 Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I hate when I have to be subbed unless
it's to this channel click subscribe
button so you can sit and watch just
like me